this is a production of cornell
university
for those of you who haven't been to
greenwood greenwood is
was founded in 1838 it's a active
cemetery a national historic landmark
and an arboretum and the national
historic landmark designation is one
that you see when you approach our main
gates
and if you can read that description
there it says established in 1838 this
was the largest and most varied of the
early american rural cemeteries
carefully cited with dramatic views of
the city and harbor beyond
they're paying specific attention to the
importance of this landscape
of the vistas that it provided and where
it was located
but what kind of landscape is this well
if we think about it we give a lot of
credit to our
charismatic megaflora here which are our
trees but we don't pay much attention to
the things that people walk upon
and the largest
by far um
plant community that we have at
greenwood is a grassland community
and so what is an urban grassland well
you guys can all read this
definition here but it encompasses a lot
of
places that are usually overlooked as
being
grasslands soccer fields community
gardens private yards
golf courses and parks
all fall under this category so let's
put aside the urban forest concept for
the time being and really look at these
landscapes as urban grasslands and
specifically because
they require in
an immense amount of inputs to manage
properly
so you'll see this on the screen here
it's 12
000 gallons of gasoline used to manage
greenwood's 400 acres of
407 acres of turf now
you when you see the equivalence here of
how much that
is it really should put it into stark
contrast about the amount of resources
that are applied to managing this as a
grassland
you know we have these large trees we
devote a lot of care
to diversifying our collection managing
the older specimen in our collection
but when it comes down to it
we could plant trees until the cows come
home but if we can't figure out a way to
sustainably manage our
our grassland it's it's sort of a drop
in the bucket for what we can do
so this leads to our talk tonight and
and i'm looking at the letter that i
wrote him um in july 6th of 2015
7 30 p.m i
wrote my name is joe chap and i was
giving you this is to frank rossi my
name is joe sharp
i have long admired and respected your
work and have learned a great deal from
your podcast
ibooks and various research resources on
the turf site
i was wondering if you would like to
visit greenwood get a tour of our
grounds and discuss some of our turf
concerns
if a visit so i go on it's a very polite
gentle letter that was summarily ignored
for it started out polite yeah
it changed a little bit in tone later on
but it was
it started out earnest and polite and
the re the reason i wrote frank is
because i
had heard that he was the preeminent
urban turfgrass
specialist and what what i was concerned
with was two things
the amount of inputs that we were using
to manage this landscape
from herbicide to carbon emitting
machines
and also the prevalence of bermuda grass
which is an invasive grass that we're
going to talk about a little bit later
but that was taking over the landscape
we could tell that what we were doing to
manage the landscape wasn't working
so i began a dedicated
approach of harassment to get frank to
come down here
finally he did and we began what has now
be
ended this past year but was a
three-year partnership really studying
the effects of climate change in urban
grassland and that
grassland being greenwood so we wanted
to accomplish both of these goals we
wanted to reduce greenhouse gas
gas emissions we wanted to stop using
herbicide
and we wanted to increase the ecosystem
services that could be provided by an
urban grassland
so that's the origin story
i'm going to turn it over to frank frank
lauren
thank you joe uh good evening everyone
thank you so much for taking the time
joe thank you for the introduction sarah
thank you for organizing this
and keeping us on task and on track um
i'm so pleased to be uh with you here
honestly you know joe says the project
and project ended but i think the formal
project
uh where we had where we learned how to
study this place
um start has just begun
and i think getting your arms around a
landscape is complex
in such a unique space in such a unique
and historic
glacial ancient landscape if you will uh
it's been really a pleasure to apply the
little bit of plant science skills i've
developed in my 30-year career
on this wonderful landscape with these
wonderful people so
i'm here to tell you about some of the
science that we've enacted
to try to help joe and the cemetery
understand this but
presumably i can i can tell you from the
get go it's a very
narrow look at right it's a look through
a person who primarily studies
intensively managed turf grass
landscapes golf courses
uh parks athletic fields
and of course the american law and
honestly we've looked at this project as
a way of beginning to introduce
ideas into the culture into management
into operations that leads to maybe some
transformation of the american law
it begins with viewing this grassland
for what it can do not just what it
looks like
because what it looks like is only one
component of the services these kinds of
landscapes can provide to us
these natural landscapes these
plant-based landscapes
now now again it is an anthropomorphic
view of this right
it's a view of how does this serve us
and you know you can take the set
exception to that but on the other hand
what it does is it helps us
understand how the things we do
connect to the broader uh world
both natural world and
so looking at ecosystem services from a
scientific perspective my colleague here
and our uh associate dean of extension
at cornell now
jenny gowniffin and her graduate student
grant thompson
applied this framework uh to looking at
urban grasslands
several years ago when i was working on
grants committee
for his phd here and it was really
revolutionary to start to look at turf
grass manage turfgrass systems
uh in this particular way from an
academic perspective
now when you think about ecosystem
services you have to
sort of learn some language right what
does that mean well
you know here's what it means if you're
in an urban environment in portland
and you're surveying the green space and
you're saying okay
we got green stuff everywhere in
portland what is it
well it's either lawn grass short shrub
tall shrub woodlands or an occasional
tree here and there
and then what do these things do
for us from an ecosystem's perspective
not all of them
not all of them presumably but a few of
them so let's look at how things help
with runoff right
superstorm standing comes through and
does greenwood help with
retaining some of the runoff well i can
tell you it does it so well it washed
out
ravine path and many other things when
the storm came through obviously
but also you see lawn grass systems can
help with purifying the air
in a measurable way right this is data
that they can take on how the air is
cleaner
around lawn grass areas carbon storage
you know if you're looking at the lift
of carbon storage in the urban
environment
you better be looking at trees right
you're looking primarily at the
beautiful majestic trees
that make up the landscape that is green
right obviously grasslands and trees
provide some pooling
and also recreation is a big service
that the lawn grasses provide
now we're going to talk more about these
other ecosystem services later when
sarah rejoins us to provide that
expertise at the end
but let me tell you essentially we talk
about how we study
climate change but i will tell you
honestly
what we studied was the downstream
adaptations
that people who manage these complex
landscapes
have to make to adjust their landscape
management to address
the way the climate is changing so
dramatically in the urban landscape
either because it's more heavily
disturbed right it gets beat up more
or because it's getting warmer more
rapidly because of
pavement but no matter what you gotta
bury people you gotta plant grass you
gotta cut
grass i mean at the end of the day
there's 407 acres of grass
that's got to be managed in a climate
sensitive intelligent
and what we believe to be a much more
sustainable way
of managing this complex landscape and
it begins
with being data driven so where do you
get the data from well you get the data
through a lens of what a grass guy like
me thinks
you know we should attack it as right
joe
notices these issues sarah deals with
these issues
what how do we approach it from a
research perspective
to be able to get this operation on a
path
that allows it to adapt to the climate
that's so rapidly changing
i wish i could give you more numbers
about other things
sarah has really done the only lift
really
honestly in figuring out what those
measurable
changes and advancements that we make
are i'm busy trying to get the operation
adjusted to make those adaptations
so first off we started studying the
bermuda test right
then it was reducing momentum then it
was developing
from reducing mowing these perpetual
metal areas right
and then we also have looked into
resurfacing and soil handling
however because we want to keep this
short i'm only going to be able to talk
to you about those first three things
tonight
so to really give a good a good treat as
to
what we're doing all right another thing
i'm not going to talk about to any
measurable degree
because we only began literally to
scratch the surface
even though we worked with the
scientists to start to characterize some
of these soils
uh professor shaw
uh and folks at the urban uh uh the
urban soil institute
uh at brooklyn college um have have done
uh quite a bit with students there we've
been sort of studying the disturbance
handling of the soil
we're not going to talk a lot about this
but let me tell you
this is its own world under greenwood
and the way we have to intentionally
disturb it
is something that is worthy of a lot
more attention
than i was able to give it in our
particular study now
let's look at this bermuda best paul you
see this brown stuff here
this is what it looks like for about two
and a half
three months a year throughout the
landscape
and essentially as we've been able to
characterize it
maybe about 25 we've got close to about
10
of the land we estimate out there now to
be made up of this bermuda grass plant
this is a plant that has been able to be
successful not just because of the
shifting climate
because once it got introduced it made
it it immediately
uh thrive in a heavily disturbed area
where where you dig a lot of holes you
plant a lot of grass
you mow and bang into things and turn on
things
and the soil gets disturbed and that
kind of an
environment is really conducive to this
plant
once it got there we're beginning to
understand some of the origins of that
once it got there the way it's managed
and the changing climate has led to
dramatic expansion
and you can sorry i was gonna i was
gonna say that it's not just this
glaring
aesthetic issue that these photos
demonstrate
it's also the fact that this grass when
it's growing
grows over everything all right we're
going to get to that
so so here you see
when it gets dormant right the color
that it takes on right in front of the
chapel
in an area that was recently renovated
right before we started working with the
cemetery
now it also is impacted a bit by shade
now this is where
you know the arboretum comes in and the
conflict with well you plant a tree you
can't bury somebody there right so
there's always going to be these
conflicts in these grasslands
that are very interesting to have to
deal with and i'm sort of curious joe
as you think about this maybe make this
conversational right here
how do you have to then adapt the way
you approach
planting trees because i'm going to tell
you one solution to the bermuda grass
issue
is in fact planting trees
so what exactly is your question though
frank
how are you going to plant more trees
when you need to keep burying people
that that's a really direct way of
asking it so i appreciate that
um it's a balancing act we realize that
each
um space that's devoted to a tree is it
possible
it might not be able to accommodate a
burial so that there's no loss in
revenue but it's a balancing act between
the cemetery
needing to generate revenue and us
needing to plant trees at the same time
we work with our civil engineer sara's
worked really hard on
on using our survey maps to find
opportunities for tree planting
and what we're trying to do right now is
use an approach
that we established a few years ago
which is basically planting trees in
groves
so densely planting certain areas and
then planting along
the streets as la's which are basically
street
tree-lined streets or roads here in
greenwood so that grove style planting
allows us to sort of capitalize on the
available space
space from existing lots um and work
around
the parameters the picture that frank's
showing here is there's very little
opportunity for us to plant
here but more opportunity elsewhere
and it has enormous impact on bermuda
grass because warm season grasses
are shade intolerant they
absolutely do not tolerate particularly
under regularly mode conditions now if
you don't mow them
art pressing will tell you they go
pretty they grow pretty good under his
birch trees there
but once you start mowing them under
shade they really don't tolerate that
very well and here's just some of the
data
we've been able to generate looking back
at the models of leafing
lethal temperatures and chilling
temperatures
it looks like about 1965 when we crossed
a critical threshold
where the lethal temperatures and the
chilling temperatures were no longer
consistently low enough
to result in dramatic kill and that's
very interesting when you consider a few
polar vortexes have come in
over the last several years and have had
virtually no
uh impact on the bermuda grass
population as we see it
uh in in greenwood right now
now uh i want to get through some of
this stuff just to tell you a little
smitten of what we're doing
uh we put sensors into the landscapes
we've identified
this is a map of the greenwood cemetery
looking at the microclimates
we've done quite a bit of climate
modeling microclimate modeling
uh at the cemetery basically getting it
instrumented
for future study as well this will allow
us to know
quite a bit more about microclimate
effects as we become more site-specific
in the way we manage the property
so let me start out with a couple of the
ways we attack the bermuda fasting
we plant a lot of grass at greenwood and
you know we don't
really have a good way of evaluating how
one grass might do better than another
grass so we had this opportunity in the
wisteria area
to replant with the bright fruit crew
replant an area
where the stones were getting leveled
and you can see where that's all
happening here
the goal is to identify some different
grasses uh try some different mixes go
back to some old ways to think and try
some progressive ideas
and see if that helped us number one
look good number two
keep out the bermuda grass we we did a
variety of mixtures
and blends here uh with different
species and varieties there some
motivated by some of the old-fashioned
pasture and bent grass mixes
that were probably used back in the late
1800s
when the cemetery was originally planted
some local
native species mixes that we got from
some long island folks
and then uh some more traditional turf
grass mixes
uh that might perform better uh under
lomo
so uh we established them we looked at
their establishment over time and of
course if you're going to be data driven
i got to show you some data
and so we looked at the percent cover
how rapidly the plots established that
they were planning
and we saw you know relatively rapidly
most of the mixes
except for a few really established very
quickly which is
one way that these mixes could uh
keep out the warm season grasses if they
establish rapidly
maybe they'll be effective in keeping
out the bermuda grass
and yet what we found was almost
immediately
even with chemical use prior to
the planting even with new soil
brought from off-site that did not have
bermuda grass
in it even with those facts there still
remained bermuda grass in these brand
new plots and again
looking at that data right here are the
different mixes that we use
the amount of bermuda grass there very
low population
uh here at the zero end and very high
population there at the top
and we said well if you get a rating of
about five
that's about as much bermuda grass as we
can tolerate once it
gets above that dark line it's really a
problem
and what you can see is no surprise from
the
in the course of the one season we've
seen
significant invasion of bermuda grass
into some of these other areas
now some of the current areas that are
still going
are keeping the bermuda grass at bay
here's a a look at the packs
pasture mix that had a little bit of red
clover in there to fix some nitrogen in
the atmosphere
and here's what the clover here's what
the pasture mix looked like
on when was i there though joe was i
there monday
yes monday so this is a picture from
monday uh you can see the trees in
beautiful flower there
and a pretty good looking pasture mix
but i can tell you this mix is gonna
grow more
it looks really good in the spring it
suffered a little bit in the summer
and again we took off taking a whole
bunch of data on the way these things
look
here's the way it looked uh in june of
last year
uh after it was established and here's
what it looked like on monday
and it really has kept the bermuda grass
out you can see a few
uh weeds invading there and and i can
tell you we've learned a lot about
how objectionable weeds are to people
and how some herbicide use might be
required
in some areas where the clientele simply
demand
not having weeds there and so when we
look at the overall assessment of some
of these things again
that acceptable level is what in this
case we want to be
above in this case we want to be above
and in this case you can see we only
have a few mixes
that have really persisted well uh and
gotten pretty good data
performance in the time we've been doing
all right
so um one way of managing the invasive
bermuda grass has been to look at
modifying resurfacing and soil handling
and the other way has been to go in
there and try to plant grasses that keep
it out
the other thing we've been charged with
doing is altering mowing
right and this became probably the
biggest technological lift i've ever had
to work on
uh that didn't involve some bench
science where i was doing something in a
lab we
outfitted a whole bunch of mowers with
gps devices that you can see the trace
on in the background there
so i want to talk to you a little bit
about the use of technology
but it began with understanding how the
plants
actually grew uh that we were mowing now
the low hanging fruit so to speak
was um the raising of the mowing height
soon as we were charged with doing this
we worked with our outsourced contractor
brightview
and our perpetual care in-house team
and we said listen let's raise
everybody's height of cut to three
inches
and let's even go to four inches in some
places where we can
and the reason we do that is by raising
the height of cut
it allows you to extend the mowing
interval
because the grass grows quite a bit
slower
when it's mowed higher the closer you
mow grass
the more it grows the higher you mow
grass
the slower it grows and so we started
measuring
you know i'm in a line of work where you
get paid to watch the grass
so i had a technician lowell chamberlain
who did just some excellent work down
there with us for
a couple of years uh came to us from the
peace corps and i think now
might be heading off to the service into
the air force uh but for a couple of
years he was measuring how grass grew
and this is the point joe was raising
early we looked at how the cool season
grasses did
right the grasses that would normally
grow around here that we want to have
and how did the bermuda grass grow the
warm season grass that slowly invaded
so this is centimeters of growth per
week
and this black line is the line
that we can't exceed in growth
and maintain the mowing schedule that
we're on
that means that the grass is growing at
such an excessive rate
that our mowing regime cannot keep up
with it
so when you look at these areas
underneath these curves
first off you notice the cool season
grass slow to start growing
now it's growing about an inch a week by
mother's day right by the beginning of
june
it's growing close to you know about an
inch and a half a week
right now you start to see the warm
season grass bermuda grass
actually starts to grow more rapidly
earlier in the season than the cool
season grasses
and then you can see slowly grows
more than an inch a week until mid-july
and then once the heat hits in this
particular year
in mid-july you can see bermuda grass
was
literally growing two inches per
week so when joe was saying it grows
over the top of everything
the implications of that is if you want
to stop mowing
you've got a plant that grows pretty
aggressive if you would like to mow
less you would not want to have this
grass
in there because it's simply growing so
rapidly
in brooklyn it's literally some i can
tell you honestly
brass the bermuda grass grows better
in brooklyn than it does in southern
california
or even in the mountains of arizona like
scottsdale arizona we
get a little bit of cool weather we grow
we have a longer bermuda grass growing
season
in brooklyn than we have in southern
points of the united states
which means when you go to mograss
you gotta sort of match up how it grows
with how rapidly you mow it so we at the
same time we're measuring growth
we were measuring mowing productivity so
we put
gps trackers on all the mowers we did a
weekly analysis of the program that we
were adapting for this called fairway iq
as you might imagine by the name if
we're adapting it from the golf business
that nothing exists that actually does
this
so we stuck all these sensors on the
brightview mowers
and we compiled the information and then
processed the data
to be able to do one you know many many
things with that data as i'll show you
in a minute
but one of the things was well you got
400 acres
and it basically you can see your
productivity
if you're gonna cut the cemetery 13
to 15 times a year you have to mow
about 200 acres uh a week
and that's what this black line is so
our data
indicated that it took the mowing
company a little bit to get up to speed
and then did a pretty good job in fact
productivity was great until july
and then it starts to drop off a little
bit then picks up again and then it
drops off and stays below 200 acres now
the interesting thing about this is if
you notice
look at what the cool season grass
growth looks like at this time of year
it really starts to drop off
dramatically
after that august time period where
the warm season grass is still growing
very aggressively
so you know if i was in the mowing
business and was mowing in brooklyn
i would think well my full season
grasses aren't growing very much
but what this could indicate is our
mowing demands could be even greater
as the bermuda grass continues to invade
the cemetery
now the other thing we're able to do
well actually you know what joe
let me shut up here for a minute let me
see if there's any questions
sarah joe any questions on anything i've
said to this point
because we're going to take a a little
bit of a hard left here in a second
and get into some more productivity and
operational research
but i i've dumped a lot on you about the
way bermuda grass grows
the implications of its invasion and how
we've begun to surveil the mowing
program
in addition to all the different grasses
and systems that we put out there
and begun to evaluate so joe sarah what
do you think
questions or you guys got any comments
or want to color in a little bit or what
go ahead oh no i was just gonna say
frank i think you've been
so succinct because no one has plugged
in any
questions everyone is just absorbing the
information
according to emily um but i did just
want you to just like go over and
emphasize how
the data is sort of the implications of
the data that you have collected
are based on a standing threshold as
our aesthetic expectations hold
currently
right like that is
that is the variable that's being that's
like the baseline variable that's being
the lens that's being looked at
it's it's a as you as i've learned boy i
got speechless sarah it's such a good
question you shut me up that's that's
i can tell there's so many layers to
this as you two know and maybe many on
the call who have any intimacy with
greenwood
there's this there's a couple of things
i would i learn
in this process that i think are worthy
of share
number one is there are very different
perceptions
of this landscape if you have someone
buried there
or you're a lot owner versus whether
you're
a citizen just visiting with no
uh formal association let's say
uh with the cemetery there definitely
is a dichotomy of the way the landscape
is
is viewed and the lens with which it is
viewed now
if we can all agree on that and
focus on who pays the bills and
who writes the emails and who sends the
complaints
because of the size and scale of this
operation
and because of the downsizing that's
occurred in operations like this like it
happened everywhere else
it becomes in many ways a complaint
driven
operation and so then we wind up being
beholden to the squeaky wheels
and that then sarah answers your
question
about the pressures that this urban
grassland is under
as are many homeowner association lawns
as are well a lot of neighborhoods and
scarsdale lawns
right that have like the neighbors so so
again
this being a proxy for the american law
and sarah it's a perfect question
for everybody to consider that this is
done through the lens of the modern
industrialized mechanically managed
lawn that's great um susan a did just
ask
how did you remove the bermuda grass
when we planted wisteria
the new species and variety area
we treated two-thirds of that area with
glyphosate
and one third of that area with final
sand the omri
uh listed um non-selective product
so um i and so and then uh waited seven
days
removed that material
that goes uh into the soil pile for
processing
and then new top soil was uh
applied and compacted
that answer your question answer the
questions here
yeah i think it answered it yeah
in fact we put um just you know for
uh exploratory purposes you know and i'm
a scientist
who is interested in what people are
doing we partnered with the scots
company and put in
their genetically modified kentucky
bluegrass
here at greenwood that they are planting
that can be planted on a commercial
basis now
scots has kentucky bluegrass uh three
varieties that are ground up resistant
as well as
use less water and can take less mowing
require less mowing and then they
develop a warm season grass
uh st augustine grass that uh you know
the alarming thing about that i'll tell
you honestly is that
the sod producers in the south have
adopted that technology rapidly
uh they're planting i would say close to
70 percent of the sod market in the
south that's going to be planted the
glyphosate tolerant st augustine mix
so lest you think that that issue is
just related to agriculture i promise
you
it is uh cheap and effective and and
it's going to be
in the absence of uh outcry it's going
to get tested and used so
i can tell you uh we didn't give it any
any special treatment we got sod donated
we got seed we laid it down
and it it got treated like everything
else and i can tell you it promptly died
yeah it did not have the fitness to
persist
in an environment uh like greenwood
where it wasn't going to get tender love
and care
yeah i know in new york state um the
city just passed the banding
like they're they banned the use of
glyphosate
um in playgrounds um
and just based on some activists there's
some pushback to actually for new york
state to ban it all together um
you know a monoculture just
genetically modified grasses just
in my mind might create some feral
effects that
get out of our control like we always
say
yeah i don't want to go down the glide
straight wormhole all right
go there and never come back uh but i
can tell you i know it's so deep
well i can tell you honestly um i think
it's responsible right now
to ally public concern in many ways that
in public facing or public
interaction places that you know we
limit its use
i think that's smart um i think a lot of
people are doing it but i can tell you
the people holding on to glyphosate the
most are the native plant people
people trying to maintain native
landscapes that are under siege
from real invasive plants nasty things
hogweed wild garlic japanese steelcrafts
you name it uh they really
it's it's it's it's i can only say that
these natural areas are
simply under siege now let me unless
there's other questions sarah let me get
back to yakking what do you think
go back away yeah all right all right
so so so so the next uh chapter in the
story is still about
mowing but this is again you know one of
the things i felt
really i wanted to do with joe was very
interesting to me as well is
you know he's got to manage with our and
sarah this relationship with an
outsourced
partner and we have a brightview crew
that remains
that continues to manage the perpetual
care lots
so we have two crews doing mowing sorry
just to clarify that we have a greenwood
crew
so yeah you said brightview crew so we
have a
greenwood crew sorry greenwood crew that
manages the perpetual care lots thank
you for clarifying that joe
so you've got you know two different
crews out there mowing
so we have the tracking data that we put
in manually into this spreadsheet
and began to look at the intervals
between
how often bright you most so we figured
out right team bows the whole cemetery
every 13 days on average and then
through some
uh handwritten data collection we found
out that the pc lock crew
visits uh each island about every 16
days
and there are these uh relationships
that we have with our
perpetual care uh people and
sarah and joe please help me out here
that i believe
and i don't even know if i'm using the
right terminology joe and sarah so
please correct me if i'm wrong
but we have this relationship with
people who have this perpetual care
whether it depending on the amount of
and doubt the size of the endowment
the least everybody gets as best i know
it joe
is their plot mode every seven days
that's good enough for this okay yeah
yeah
okay so the goal is to make sure the
perpetual care lots of mode every seven
days
right view modes every 13 days the
uh the brightview i'm sorry the
greenwood crew moves every 16 days
and so we analyze the the data from
brightview and the data from greenwood
and we put it together and we said well
the average interval between
these two uh mowing operations was
between
six and seven days lo and behold and in
fact
when you narrow it down further and say
okay um
was how often were they within five to
nine days
of actually mowing you know you know
either
every five days or every nine days so 82
of the time um you know we're getting
these lots uh 80 to 84 percent of the
time we're getting these lots
mowed within a five to nine day period
and about
20 of the time or 18 of the time
uh we're getting the mode outside the
five to nine days so we looked at the
data even
further and we said okay well how often
when we're outside the five to nine day
period
are we longer than that and it's only
about
ten percent of the time so ninety
percent of the time our mowing operation
is in fact uh meeting the needs of our
perpetual care
uh folks now i i just go drill into this
a little bit
um the data says you know that you're
when you use data like this
you can have an assurance that your
operation
is at least meeting its goals now what
is very interesting to us
and i think sarah and joe would agree we
want to ground true
this with time and location because
we're somewhat of a complaint driven
operation at the grassland level um
you know it's going to be essential for
determining
you know how we mow because going back
to the way grass grows
right we know that the dawn grass grows
so fast
mowing it every week might not even be
enough
right so this gets to sarah's broader
questions
about you know what are we married to
with having a grassland like this
in 2021 and it looks like the current
mowing productivity
is going to be hampered by the growth of
these grasses because especially with
the warm season grasses growing
uh more and more okay so let's get to
the end here
where we're talking about maybe
completely
transforming the way we mow and creating
these perpetual meadows
that enhance ecosystem services in a way
that we can measure and sarah's just
done such a wonderful job
on here's one of those pictures of the
40 acres
that's currently being used uh and and
developed through the growing season out
at greenwood now
and so just to give you a timeline lest
you think this was an easy process
lest you think like wow 40 acres that's
maybe not very much or 40 acres wow
that's a lot
uh whether you're half empty or a half
full person
i choose to be a half full person for
the nature of this project
the timeline of how this has come about
is that it started in
june of 2019. we identified about 100
acres that we were going to stop
mowing until november
and then another 100 acres roughly that
we
were going to start going from mowing
every two weeks
to grow mowing them monthly we're gonna
mold them now
at five inches much higher higher cut
and mow them less frequent
well let's just say that by august 2019
we had completely resumed regular mowing
on about a hundred acres uh of the
ground so we
had to resume mowing it was there's a
variety of things
that we learned here that i'm sure we'll
talk about as we get going but let's
just suffice it to say
we for a complaint driven organization
i can say we got our fair share of
complaints now joe and sarah might say
well i don't know if we got any more
complaints
i don't know if there were any different
complaints but they were enough
for us to have to change the way we
our plan was to create meadows and
change them all
so then one of the things that became
very clear was that
you know maybe it's okay you don't mow
but oh my goodness gracious weeds or
weeds
are everywhere weeds are everywhere
right so there was
a compromise that was struck eventually
that got us down to approximately 48
because i think it's 43 some auditors
that we've now been able to keep a
perpetual matter
and we implemented some pre-emergent and
post-emergent wheat control in october
2009
and in the spring of 2020 and in the
fall of 2020
and now again in the spring of uh 21.
we now have begun to cease we ceased
mowing
in june of 2020 on those 40 acres
and began to manage um that
uh meadow through the year and i want to
talk a little bit about where we are
with that now because it's a perfect
transition to
sarah being able to talk about the
benefits of these areas
first off we developed a specification
that now becomes part of the operation
because of some of the data we've
developed
now we've currently adopted adapted this
a little bit further
but that was the original move was to
create specs that we can work with our
outsourced contractor to develop these
48s
we also monitored using data how well
they did the timing of these meadows and
what kind of equipment they used they
had to use specialized equipment to mow
the meadow
at five inches and they had to do it at
the right time
and you can see we're able to monitor
their adherence to the specifications
we then went out over the during the
pandemic and and
and took data on the meadows now that we
had the weed control done
we left some untreated areas we had a
real good sense of how this was going to
perform
and so first we looked at weed weed
pressure you know
relatively weed free on the left here
versus
an enormous amount of nutsedge and
annual grasses
that begin to grow so obviously the
characteristics from an aesthetic
perspective for weeds
was a big issue the next was stone
visibility
right is how you know rating of four are
very
you know very obscured a rating of six
means
uh relatively visible right you can
still see them
uh even though the grasses are not being
mold
right now we looked at lodging right how
much
are they bent over right seven is lots
of lodging
four is only some lodging that they bent
over right
so then we looked at overall general
appearance
how do they look some weeds some
obscured stones
less weeds stones are more visible and
this
really is where our work now transitions
very nicely sarah to some of the things
that you were able
to measure out there about what
introducing some of these 40 acres
uh might have done so um i don't know if
you want to take questions or if you
want to just transition right into you
to start talking
how do you want to handle
um joe are there any questions currently
if not we only have about 12 minutes
left until
seven and i would like for to leave room
at the end just for everyone to chat so
go
after it sarah get out right girl run
into it
i'm gonna stop sharing you got the
screen i got it
yeah all right all right so what was
happening in tandem
with the launch of the urban grasslands
research was
a pretty extensive two-year wildlife
survey
it was conducted by a biologist from
applied ecological services
which is a firm down in philadelphia
correct me if i'm wrong joe
and one of the sub surveys was looking
at our wild bees the wild bee survey was
conducted by
sarah kornbluth and parker gambino they
are
research scientists stationed at the
american museum of
natural history and they study and
survey the bees in
new york why i mentioned wild bees
is that wild bees are
the presence of them the diversity of
them they are an indicator of
ecological health um and i will go
and also they're incredibly important to
the
ecosystem services that
uh frank alluded to earlier so some of
the provisioning
they're really important for agriculture
um they are
here responsible for pollinating 80
percent of flowering plants
they are foundational to the local food
web
which if you are you know keeping an ear
in sorry
something keeps popping up on my phone
uh keeping an ear to
just the research on insects
the biomass of insects have actually
declined by approximately 75 percent
globally and our wild bees are highly
endangered
honeybees are not wild i just want to
plug that in
because most people do think that
honeybees are one
native to here and that
they're domestic we should only view
honeybees as a
domesticated animal um we farm them
um there are 4 000 native bee species in
north america
and through this survey um we found 62
native species
at greenwood uh
so i wish i overlaid
frank's map of the meadow areas
um but i promise you the meadow areas
align
with the blue dots most of the blue dots
on this map
so the number of genre and
by genre by genre i mean it's the
taxonomic rank that falls
above the species level and below the
family level
18 different genre were surveyed at
greenwood
and as you can see the highest number
of genre appeared around areas that were
either managed as meadow were gardens
or areas that just had less frequent
mowing so just less disturbance
because the areas areas that did have
less frequent mowing
you know a lot of the floral were able
to
come to a flower occasionally you had
the ephemeral appearance of
those floral resources um
and i'm gonna bring up so if no one
there are some people who are not in new
york or in brooklyn right now
so greenwood coming to the space
it is not quite homogenous there are
valleys
there are hills some areas are more
you know densely shaded with large trees
other you know and then other areas open
up to wide vistas
um this is an example of part of a
landscape where aesthetically
we it looks you know full and vibrant
of life and flowers but in fact you know
the plants that we see right now that
are currently in bloom they're not in
bloom for that long
um and this area as you can see
is being managed not as meadow so it is
being mowed more
frequently so there are no floral
resource or very few floor resources
that are able to appear
so we look at our bees look at this
and other pollinators look at this as a
food desert
um this is a different example of
it is a really steep sloped
area over by our historic chapel
in the background and this was designed
by larry weiner landscape associates and
this is about a 1.9 acre
area that had that has been planted with
72
native uh perennials and shrubs and this
is one of the areas i'm just going to go
back
and i will use my cursor this is the
areas with one of
the highest amount of genre surveyed
of wild bees
um and then you've seen this before
this is the area that's managed as
meadow
and although it doesn't look like much
there still is more significant
diversity of bees surveyed there
than say the pollinator food desert
which is actually right over here around
area four
i wanted to include this because if it
wasn't
for the experiment that we launched
where we
effectively took 100 acres out of mowing
rotation
we would have not been able to find
claytonia virginiana
springing up uh this is commonly known
as spring beauty it's a
aphamel ephemeral native wildflower
and it's endemic to new york city and
new york state but previously we had
never noticed it we had never noticed it
and that is
again because the landscape is being
mowed we were never
able to it was never able to come to
flower
oh good lisa says she saw this over the
weekend
um so one of the efforts that we began
uh was when we saw patches of claytonia
popping up
we roped it off so that mowers would not
mow the flowers
and we left this until the end
of their flowering season so that they
could be pollinated and come to seed and
the seed could be returned to the seed
bake
and we could expand pollinate or expand
yeah
pollinator habitat um
i hate to do this plug with honeybees
again but conserving pollinators is not
protecting the honeybees pollinator
conservation is actually habitat
conservation
um and bringing just bringing it back
to uh the
the waste that is produced when we
manage these landscapes
as joe mentioned these are the numbers
as it pertains to greenwood
by taking 40 acres out of normal
rotation and converting it to meadow we
effectively reduced
our greenhouse gas gas emissions about
24
uh relatedly to just all of new york
city
um the new york city land cover type
this data was taken from the natural
areas conservancy
then i broke it down into smaller
numbers just to
really flesh out some of the impact um
so to just
mow with uh two
two-stroke engines gasoline power mowers
and trimmers
would pretty much be the same as adding
963 cars to the streets
of new york city
i actually looked this up previously
there's just under
two million cars so this would be adding
you know like an additional it would
effectively be like five percent of
the vehicle the registered vehicles and
in new york city
um i also just wanted to emphasize that
cemeteries are comprise a pretty
significant
land parcel in new york so
the impact that cemeteries can have just
by changing the way that they are
managing their lawns
is very significant um
lastly because i want us to wrap us up
so we can talk
um whenever we're talking about
greenhouse gas emissions it's always
related to like the abstraction of the
climate but i did just want to
uh just just sort of like bring back
into our focus and our imagination that
the uh gasoline mowers and trimmers
according to the epa are emitting about
124
times more volatile um organic compounds
into the air so that includes like
carbon monoxide
and nitrous oxides uh carbon monoxide is
incredibly harmful to
human health um it replaces oxygen in
the blood
in the bloodstream and then uh nitrogen
oxide when it's emitted
it reacts with heat and sunlight
specifically and it
will convert into smog and particulate
matter
which over prolonged period of time
communities who live in
areas where there are these points of
emissions
can develop asthma and all other health
issues
but the ground level ozone also known as
smog also has deleterious effects
on the plant life in the area as well
so there are some species here that are
sensitive to ground level ozone
and what this does is it risks them to
disease
and weakening over time because it
essentially slows their it interferes
with their ability to photosynthesize
and so they're growing slower which
conversely means that they are not
sequestering as much carbon dioxide as
we would like or as they are able to
and then this just has ripple effects
into the ecosystem so it degrades
it reduces habitat quality it changes
the water nutrient cycles that we also
covered in terms of like
what ecosystem services are going so
that's where i wanted to end on and
let's chat
i'm gonna stop the share thank you sarah
it's it's great to see that stuff um
and i can tell you we saw blue stem come
up when we stopped mowing
joe i think there's other treaties that
you found uh
when we stopped mullin um you know
that's a landscape that that evolved
from
no mechanical mowing to essentially
being
entirely governed by mechanical mode the
entire landscape is
whatever's not a tree is essentially
selected for because it tolerates
frequent mode frequent mowing used to
mean weekly now it means bi-weekly and
a little bit longer and i think there's
a lot more opportunities but
i think sarah and joe you would agree
safety remains a big issue in a place
like a cemetery in the world of push
pull
that we live in some of these uh areas
that we let go for a while
um can occasionally be safety problems
joe because because they're trip hazards
yeah no that's exactly right
they might look beautiful as meadows but
they do obscure the stones to the point
where someone might trip
but i will ask a question now from the
chat
sure how much time do you have for this
one
what what is the definition of a of a
weed what was the definition of a weed
ah
i think whitman or waldo emerson said
it's a plant whose virtues we have not
realized
it's my favorite that is
yeah weeds are uh you know we generally
weeds are something that of course like
everything else grew out of our
agrarian society where they got in the
way of crop production
essentially we define them as things
that disrupt the function of the site
and if the function of the site is to
produce 100 bushels of corn
that plants in the way right now when
you take it all the way evolve it to a
cemetery in the american lawn
you have a very subjective uh
you have a very subjective environment
that you
that you're in now except for this
annual weeds that are not perennial or
perennial plants that don't play nice
with the other plants and allow for a
diverse
planting our plants we've gotta
that disrupt in my opinion disrupt the
function of the site the primary
function of the site for a place like
brooklyn
is to get the water into the soil so it
doesn't run off and wash out the city
or flow it into the east river with all
the pollutants and keep the area cool
right hold the water and it's like in
fact
like a big air conditioner in the middle
of a really tough part of brooklyn
so you know i think about it as like
that's its primary function and if you
don't have plants
everywhere like you got crabgrass and
you got
plants that don't grow well there and
then die off for a period of year leave
bare soil the rains come
now so now the area isn't serving the
function of the site so i've got a
reason why i want that beat out of here
or if sarah now wants to have some a
little more diverse planting
but then let's say morning glory came in
or infamilia came in
a bindweed came in like we saw recently
and it starts
choking out some of these things well
now that's a week right so we've got to
get in and do some management there so
i think we're trying to broaden the
definition of weed
but joe and sarah what do our lot owners
think a weed is
any plant that's probably not turf grass
specifically
but but i'll say that i want to clarify
something you said earlier about
um the native plant people using
herbicide you know the
the not so secret truth is that in order
to establish that you know beautiful
meadow
by the chapel we had to kill the
existing turf grass there
and we had to use herbicide there's
always a balancing act in these
situations in which we're
saying is it is the outcome
worth it um yeah and i couldn't agree
more john i think
our thinking about this has evolved and
our goal is
listen my goal as a plant scientist
who's worked in this industry for
30 years is to get people from being
rely i don't want them reliant on these
things
if they're tools that they occasionally
use
for definable measurable i did it for
this
i evaluated it did that i'm okay
but if now you're just doing it
willy-nilly like the weed and feed
madness that goes on on the american
lawn every spring
you know the yankees sell it during a
game or mets are selling it during a
game
you know you see ads for these things
what we're trying to do is is get
the american public and the cemetery
public to want to embrace
less reliance and what we're finding is
we may have to zero out the population
that's there now systematically over the
next couple of years
and then institute management that then
keeps them out
that is sustainable and that's the way i
think we view
vegetation management moving forward and
if there are soft choices to do it i
think we're going to do that
and i don't begrudge anyone who has
seized a lawn that's
filled with quote unquote weeds and says
that's objectionable because it's almost
an
unconscious aversion that people have to
these landscapes they don't even
recognize the fact that when someone
sees a
overgrown lawn they think it's a sign of
neglect it's often just
immediate and what we have to do to
change this
is to make it seem to to make the
argument that it's an
intentional intervention in the
landscape in order to preserve the
landscape over time
it's not just you know we're not just
lazy
and not mowing we're actually putting
trying to say that you know mowers out
in the landscape they tend to damage the
stones because they're mowing at such a
rate that
it's just inevitable it's like you know
if a
pinball machine mowing in a cemetery so
they're going to bang into the stones
they're going to sort of cause erosion
if we keep the turf a little bit longer
if we lessen the mowing
is there a threshold between when it
becomes
a symbol of neglect and when it becomes
a symbol of intention and that's sort of
the
the line that we're looking at but
before i
go continue on my tangential
diatribe there let's look at a quote
let's look at a question here
from misty rain over time
with space in the cemetery lessening and
burial is tending toward green with the
millennial generation
could more and more lawn be turned to
unmowed grasslands
also could the public opinion dilemma
american lawnmowers unmode or native
breslin be addressed with different
different marketing from gw that's a
great question
yeah i'll leave the marketing to you and
i'll just say this
what we're talking about is managing
these meadows differently
i can tell you they take as much thought
and intention more so i would say than
simply going out and moan
man and in fact getting people to manage
these meadow areas the way we want
maybe introducing new species um
is much more complicated than sending
people out to motor landscapes
some of it is an adaptation we've made
because well
labor force is is what it is this
requires some expertise to do
and so it tends to be avoided because
you got to
pay more for expertise for people to
come in and have this kind of management
but joe's point is
well taken it gives this unkempt look
when in fact it's just being differently
managed it's not being managed
necessarily any less
it might be less from an energy
perspective but it's more from a
ecological perspective we're working
with the landscape as opposed to trying
to
bend it to our will
i'm just trying to see if i
well said frank i i'm i'm just trying to
see if i have one of these postcards
that we created we created a postcard
in the midst of a firestorm of just
immense complaints against what we were
doing
in the summer through postcards in a
fire yeah
it was like that it was like hey but we
created a
uh um an email address called it was
called grasslands at
greenwood.com and
we encourage people to write us with
their reactions
so we opened ourselves up to really
seeing what people thought
and what we
and i would go out there and talk to a
lot of lot owners and
what they would say is the argument that
you hear often from people who
care about the environment but have sort
of conflicts about how to go about
preserving it
whatever that means but they would say
you know i really like what you guys are
doing there
but don't do it on my lot do it on that
lot
so i think what we're really trying to
do is
bridge this cognitive dissonance between
what is
what we need to do um
to sort of lessen our environmental
impact here and what the outcome of that
going to be as far as your question
about you know marketing these postcards
which explain the collaboration why
we're doing what we were doing
you know i don't know if they
changed any minds i think
we we approached the first year of this
with a great deal of hubris and we
thought that no one was going to notice
when we stopped mowing 100 acres
which in hindsight is just ridiculous
but
we thought that we could try these
different things and
not get away with it but that people
would be
understanding and in the cemetery in
which there's
there's a specific emotional connection
between the
the height of turf grass this opinion of
neglect and
grieving families and so on it's much
more complicated than just saying
you know we have prospect park we won't
mow an acre of it
and people might not care you know it's
just
here it's different so we can't really
though fundamentally shift
this whole thing it needs to happen as a
sea change a bunch of actions coming
together
where people have sort of recognized
that
these urban grasslands are in your
backyard they're where your kids play
soccer
if we can change the way those areas are
managed
perhaps we can begin to shift this
american obsession with lawn so
that's my soapbox
and how often a question from kevin
zembrano
how often is gw converting spaces to
native landscapes such as the chapel
hillside
well kevin we're always looking for
opportunities um
we expanded the meadow from
1.6 to about two acres last spring
and we're always looking for
opportunities where we
can make these interventions and have
them look appropriate
you know the thing is tall grasses
don't always native to ornamental
grasses don't always
aren't always appropriate in terms of
the way they look but
converting areas to meadow
is easier than that so uh
yeah at 7 11 i sort of trailed off there
at the end kevin i'm sorry i didn't
answer your question effectively
but we're always looking for
opportunities so there's that
is there a planting plan for the del
water area it seems like it is being
more slightly managed is that part of
the study
we are in the midst of a master planning
process for del water and we're it's
going to be a really
i think an incredible transition for
that space one that i
really love in the cemetery and i think
you'll
if you like del water you're really
going to like what we do it's going to
be a few years from now but
yeah stay tuned all right
are there any more questions i do have
some
plugs of upcoming events
um so as like
almost a fortuitous series that was
planned by the gods um
i'm just kidding it was you know
scheduled and planned by joe and i
in may we're having a webinar
and a walk led by ellie irons
and ann percoco from the next epoch seed
library
they are community activists and
um environmental artists uh
they originally were based in brooklyn
but since the pandemic they've moved
elsewhere but their talk will actually
be
on the anthropocene
and the weeds that are in urban spaces
and the plant life that is colonized
that are colonizing these areas
then in june we have a webinar and a
pollinator walk
with sarah kornbluth who i mentioned
earlier from the american museum of
natural history um she will be talking
about
her uh bee survey and then in july
we have a webinar being led by richard
shaw who frank
mentioned earlier who conducted the soil
survey here and so he will actually be
doing
a little bit of soil science 101 in that
webinar
i i've been requested um a message
to stop mowing lots and plant
planting lots of weeds so we might take
you off on that
we actually don't need to plant weeds
right like
there's a there there's a ferality
to plants that is either it can be seen
as really advantageous
you know moving moving the world forward
and regenerating areas
and also the feral effects that we don't
like like
invasiveness and stuff
so i want to just say that you 22 folks
are terrific you stayed
till 7 15 on a thursday night to talk
about grass with
us so we gotta just give you guys a
round of applause thank you all for
coming out
um and you hope to come to the other
talks that we give and um
they're gonna be really good yeah okay
good night good night
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu